des pièces métalliques usées nettoyé par
décapage à très forte pression c'est le
nouveau service proposé par le site gde
groupe ecore de limay des tuyaux ou
d'autres matériaux notamment en acier ou
en fonte
revêtu de substances dangereuses comme
l'amiante des produits entrent ici
emballé sont dans une atmosphère
contrôlée
donc ça veut dire qu'il n'ya aucune
fibre qui peut sortir à l'extérieur de
l'installation et on arrive dans la
salle de traitement salles blanches ou
des opérateurs équipés en atmosphère
contrôlée en ventilation assistée traite
par ultra haute pression 2500 barre en
décapant les produits ça c'est la cuve
de tampon qui récupère les autres
process
après le traitement et le passage dans
les filtres et qui va être réutilisés
dans le dans le système une fois
décontaminer les produits sont
réutilisés par ses clients la nouvelle
unité par décapage un investissement de
500 mille euros et 4 personnes
embauchées spécialisée dans le recyclage
j'ai des retraites près de 3,7 millions
de tonnes de matières par an en fait nos
clients nous ont demandé de trouver des
solutions à leurs problématiques
environnementales et économiques
parce que jusqu'à présent ces tuyaux
étaient enfuis et donc nos clients
avaient des coûts d'enfouissement très
important la capacité de traitement est
environ 200 tonnes par mois donc 1200
tonnes à l'année et c'est un
investissement dont le retour est espéré
sur une durée inférieure à trois ans ali
mais cet outil s'ajoute au broyeur de
six mille chevaux avec une capacité de
200 mille tonnes par an et notamment des
véhicules recyclés
l'entreprise est présente sur 64 sites
en france et 11 en europe